Billy honey fed Enderlin change often a
much more open you are that is loose
tambien in Colombia what situation
wasn't a winner all to be feeling it be
one through a missile killing Conti
Macondo is a cross between a cafe and a
bar
[Music]
Jorge Rodriguez from Colombia used to
work in marketing but then he decided to
open Macondo which he runs himself he
offers a limited selection of food all
of it Colombian of course like the wine
Vulcan is so cheeky breeky cocktail like
that boom ah no just kidding relax cozy
and at home is the very home by now see
makan dough's unique charm is popular
with its guests many of whom are
regulars
when Jorge Rodriguez opened it in 2006
he was in the middle of reading the
novel One Hundred Years of Solitude by
Colombian author Gabriel Garcia Marquez
who describes a magical fictional town
called Macondo
or Pedro Regas liked the name and used
it for his cafe
[Music]
Macondo is in Berlin's trendy free
Design District ten years ago this area
had far fewer restaurants and shops but
Hort cake had a feeling it was an
up-and-coming place and he was right
young people in particular are attracted
to the district pre-design Kreuzberg is
now the most densely populated particle
in
[Music]
for the design have free design never
sleeps
Sophie live to this day many Tories who
never worry King Kai named tiny grain
size of side missus can sit on Morgan's
it's anodized he was always something
going on outside on the streets against
Eclipse here clubs in the neighborhood
do you guys have staged all the next day
like servicing their print toxins and
commented on through deep fried
plantains known as Patrick owners are
often served in Colombia for richer
version plantains are used what still
green that's when they have their
highest starch content the plantains are
deep fried or pan-fried they're
especially popular with a hearty filling
a special irony called a torte tiara is
used to crush the plantains they can
then be easily shaped as desired
[Music]
plantains are served as a snack or as a
dessert as a side or main dish the
Copelan and in the receptivity recipe
might see where I come from he made all
of Chima the how is Sima say yes my wife
and I when I said asked against him
thank her because I thought this Candy's
in my colander why Jorge Rodriguez was
born in the Colombian capital of Bogota
in 1973 he and his two brothers had a
sheltered childhood the family
vacationed regularly with his
grandparents in the coffee growing
region Armenia in central Colombia
he went on to study business management
during a business trip to New Zealand in
2002 he met his German wife to be a year
later they moved to Berlin I used to say
that how is feel ability I have
everything now I say I am not yet I've
always been knocking his pearly that
takes his home he misses his family
besides plenty of Latin American
customers come to makandal which helps
stop and feeling homesick boy you say
preparado para khones Asuna Rosetta
dem who went to spare others gusta you
later say Bon Appetit
[Music]